dormammu i've come to a place of bargain
nailing marvel lines a hundred percent
of the time guys we're gonna watch what
if episode four a doctor strange episode
listen it's my birthday on friday so
it's an early birthday present to me can
we
get you to hit that like button if we
get to 8 000 likes i'll be the kid that
brings donuts to the classroom on his
birthday
hey could you also subscribe and click
that notification bell as a birthday
present to john next june full length
watch alongs where you sync it with the
time coder over at our patreon page and
over there we cover a whole bunch of
shows we're at the same tier you get the
option for reaction highlights and watch
logs included i'm almost done with
avatar last time burp introduced a
little extra plug and uh hey uh thanks
to um i think me for editing down these
highlights i'm pretty sure i did an
awesome job good job yeah all right
sweet
[Music]
what if it's the wrong choice
what if the best of intentions
has very strange consequences haha
you're clever
clever watcher man jokes
you promised me creme brulee i suspect
we can do a little better than that
they're gonna do it on the freeway
mm-hmm
i think you should just rush the podium
like a contestant on the price is right
screaming and it's coming
i would call that quite remarkable
but i would say the same about you
i'm starting to get uneasy oh he is so
much nicer than he was in the
forgiving of the first movie it's making
me really uneasy
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
oh yeah
oh
i hope his heart is okay
something tells me oh what a great show
shot yeah shattered heart manipulation
and alteration of timelines oh no
yes this is gonna be like the time
machine remake i know he's gonna keep
trying to save her i'm going to start
the kettle i suggest you join me before
you do something reckless
do the reckless thing man yeah
wong totally walked away that's what he
does he's gonna go fight chang
he's gonna go fight abomination instead
something wrong i uh
i'm gonna run up to the podium like a
game show contestant cheers and screams
he's gonna accidentally shoot her in the
head
what do you think marvin well this is
shaping up to be a night to remember
it is like the time machinery
can't escape it's strange
i hope this isn't the whole episode
don't go to this terrible time
oh we missed our turn isn't the bridge
that way taking a different route
it's okay we'll be fine just park the
car
damn dude don't this is horrible don't
do any car stuff dance i promise you we
will have a good time
oh you gotta be shitty that's messed up
pizza you're a genius
this is so awful they they really meant
lost his heart
the unfunny version of edge of tomorrow
yeah damn why does this keep happening
allowed to be happy
you're the only thing that matters
holy christ
talk about coming to bargain
[Music]
oh
so much heavier than the other episodes
you cannot reverse an absolute point
nothing is impossible you taught me that
i only require more power
do not do this
or i will be forced to stop you
you'd have to find me first
[Music]
no
[Laughter]
a little bit of a swashbuckling vibe
here
you have to be the strangest dress
sorcerer i've ever seen yeah it's armani
[Laughter]
the lost books
it's a lot of
through the books
of other
absorption yes do that that sounds like
a good idea oh [ __ ]
oh damn
what you doing stranger oh no
i brought you here because i need to
borrow your powers do you mind sharing a
tentacle or two
mystic beings do not bargain
love can break more than your heart it
can shatter your mind
wow
and in which book did you read that
no book armani
life
taught me
that's why it's got two colored eyes now
loved it
if they won't surrender their power i'll
take it
that's what he meant
so into this
[Laughter]
wow
no no no dee strange
oh nice cape
[Music]
yes dude this feels like a classic
disney anime i don't know yeah it feels
like something out of fantasia
with a little anime sprinkled on top
[Music]
more
more mom no no mickey no look at this
this is oh
my man
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
wow the fate of his universe is not
worth risking the safety of all others i
doubt he'd listen
hell yeah
dude this is great oh man
yes
[Music]
oh no
yeah
holy crap
yes holy crap
[Music]
end of episode
[Laughter]
what i can reverse this you will live
longer forever oh he still cares i can't
accept that but maybe the other
strange will
arthur
we're only half a man
living half a life
how is the metaphor thinking i thought
he was gonna no it could be it could
still be a physical thing only doctor
strange in this universe
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh no
oh my goodness two of your possible
timelines to occur in one universe two
timelines
doubt that's the simplest or smartest
thing to do
the only sorcerer is strong enough to
stop doctor strange is
oh
jay horror ancient one
do you want to stop him
i think i have to
at the very least to save you
how would you find him
this has got to be one of like the best
he's found me marvel animated things
i've ever seen
this is so cool
[Laughter]
trippy
[Laughter]
but we are one
the world out there is breaking don't
you dare lie to me i am
you're sick bro and now can you save her
no stephen
we can
oh
no
you can't save her
oh
i've gone too far to turn back now
oh
[Music]
maybe we got doctor strange my dog
stranger
oh
god look at that shot
[Laughter]
whoa
[Music]
wizard battle
cape battle
cool
oh my god oh
god the music like everything
team up capes
[Music]
oh you're in the upside down now
oh
stephen i love you
[Music]
you're not her
definitely not a loki situation here
oh damn oh
come on man
[Music]
oh
holy hell
i was going to live here man
[Music]
it's me christine oh my god
oh my god
what's happening i saved you no this is
this this isn't real this isn't
this is hell have some self-awareness
[Music]
[Music]
this poor guy i know is he just gonna
imprison them in a crystal you can stop
this
please holy crap
the same way you fixed christine
i was wrong i read about you sensed your
presence oh but i can't interfere
meddling with time only leads to more
destruction
[Music]
oh my dude
god he works so hard
christie i'm sorry
stephen
oh
what did you do
no no no no no
crazy i know
[Laughter]
i already want to watch it again
i just want to pick apart every frame
one life one choice
one moment can destroy the entire
universe
wow holy crap
that was brilliant that was beautiful
we just finished watching this episode
of what if um holy crap
that was amazing
hoping for and
that was amazing i could see like a
full-length feature film with this man i
could not unclench my fists
youtube shorts like 15 seconds john
that's right i decided to change the
glasses and the chairs too this chair is
just more comfortable i think it's okay
it's okay i'm back where i belong back
where you belong in the distracting
spider chair
i uh i adored this one this one was like
cinematic to me yeah you know like just
because i kind of kind of used to kind
of got i got i got it because i've
gotten kind of
kind of gotten used to the flare that
what if usually provides uh at least
from the last three episodes you know i
was like having more fun with it but
then
after the sec when i started realizing
the loop is going it's going to keep
happening like she's just destined for
death because you know we've made fun of
the time machine movie we got pierce a
few times in our life because in that
movie he spends like years figuring out
time travel to save his girlfriend and
then like he goes back once she dies
again and he just like gives up after
that so i thought that's always gonna
happen it's always gonna happen and he
picked up on her really the second time
he didn't even try a third time so when
uh when they started seeing uh the
effect there of like uh the time loop
that she's like there's something that's
gonna kill her no matter what yeah
whether it's like a bullet
or just like a heart attack yeah
something's gonna kill her so she's
destined to die um that it just then the
harrowing nature of it truly started to
seep into my soul like damn this is this
is heavy stuff this is really
bleak this is a tale of grief that we're
watching now oh yeah 100
and uh i loved ha i love that they were
willing to go a lot more mature this
time around and i didn't feel that it
was ever undercut by any like comedic
moment or anything like that this could
have been like a full-length feature
film that i would have been so into
that's something that i would definitely
say about this one is
you know you assembly what if is canon
and this to me felt
like the most movie like in its
animation and it's storytelling
that i believe it to truly be a part of
you know there's a kind of thing what if
where you're like making your mind
connect to the canon yeah yeah like yeah
it's canon you know you got to keep
reminding people that for some reason
this one felt just so i was just so into
it that i was like man i wish i was in
the theater watching this one you know
like i wish this it is all of them are
can i don't know if you guys get where
i'm going with this i think you might
know where i'm going with this
it feels of great consequence you know
in a different way from the previous
feels important yeah yeah exactly like
the weight and the stakes i don't know
if it's just the efficacy of how they
portrayed them here that gets you so
caught up in them but yeah i understand
i think it's partly to me got to do with
the fact that he does manage to break
the wall and talk to the watcher yeah
and sort of you know
convene with the powers or one of the
powers that be for a hot second and so
like yeah it seems like it's piercing
further into the rules of the what if
world and also then you know too
tangentially kind of giving us hints
about like oh my god does this relate to
what doctor strange is doing it's
spider-man
like yeah it makes your mind go in a lot
of ways that seem like they could
plausibly connect to the movies uh even
though yeah we are still in this
hypothetical you know very isolated
scenario for some reason yeah it doesn't
feel isolated i mean when they were
doing the animation parts of like when
it just just got like more escala
more like it descended he just kept
going more into the hellish demonic
landscape of it all i'm like wow now i'm
so excited for multiverse of madness to
see what they can do with
all this like evil entity supernatural
crap because when they were doing that
it really felt like classic
hand draw i know it's not but or maybe
some of it is but it felt like classic
disney animation you know not you know
this like fun cute stuff that we usually
get it's all terrible you know you know
what i mean yeah
really like sleeping beauty yeah yeah
like the lushness and the true breadth
of imagination you can access via and
it's willing to go really dark and
haunting i meant that in like the most
complementary way and i think what they
did such a good job with was that they
let it breathe this episode's a few
minutes longer than the others and they
really let it breathe and i love that
they never made him go
evil you know all his motives were
rooted in love yeah well that's that's
the best part of it to me is because
throughout this journey you're following
what we think is pretty much the one dr
strange and i appreciate that when he
sets out on his mission after finally
realizing like i can't save her she's
gonna die uh and i have to do something
even crazier in order to bring her back
like part of that did just access the
swashbuckling indiana jones like wonder
of like i'm striking out i'm in a new
you know wilderness place i'm meeting
this this guy who's to guide me to this
temple filled with all the lost volumes
and like in that you don't feel like
they only gave him the note of like your
brooding and your mourning and your
ragey you know like it it managed to
feel nuanced it's funny it's like it's
also perhaps the most nuanced to just
character piece i think they've done
across these four episodes so far is it
really does feel like you just sink in
and spend some time with him and it
actually did a great job on enhancing uh
the ancient one like till the swin and i
thought that i'm assuming that's her she
did a wonderful job uh you know even
like i cared way more about christine
here than i did in the actual
live-action movie
and i really i thought it was smart of
to to tell this story this narrative in
a shorter package uh to start off with
this doctor strangers is so about him
you know being devastated over the loss
of her
where he is nicer when you first meet
him like like they hint that he's kind
of a dick but he's a lot nicer and he's
already like very romantic with
christine and it's not something of you
know just them flirting like they they
really just sped up that dynamic right
there
so that way we could get to the meat and
potatoes of the whole thing and i
thought that was really clever on their
end to do that because yeah that gets
you really invested in this version of
him
and it felt like dr strange like
it really did feel like a really
strong you know alternate scenario for
the guy it didn't
feel like oh we're doing like a
completely different take on him it is
but when you have the title of the
episode what if he lost his heart
instead of his hands
i'm like yeah that
that's probably it right there yeah yeah
it's such a tragic way that that ends
and i mean i you know you have the
reveal of i split the timeline in two
because i thought that maybe
you might be able to appeal to basically
all the good inclinations on your side
and then that the tragedy of that being
also the key to the downfall and then
him and christine just being locked in
this
crystallized
just mournful memory forever like this
was the also the first episode i think
that doesn't have like a little reversal
or a because this all happened that you
just saw this other thing will happen
next alternate universe yeah it seems
like this universe does just perish in a
really sad whimper yeah it's crazy
because you're saying like no
it's an absolute that christine must die
uh yet the absolute on the on the main
timeline is that's not the case he just
loses his hands yeah
that christine's been dealt man i know
our christine just gets to be a nurse i
know and most other christine's
other timelines are fine too but this
one this one right here though oh man
she gets a shorter in the stick she gets
to relive her death multiple times like
who fixed this here is the whole point
is you want a a lovelorn doctor strange
evil like monster creature see i thought
he was to meet our doctor strange yeah
and i thought things were going to get
so messed up yeah where he's like no i'm
still dating her
i'm sort of supreme and i'm still
sleeping
full potential and yeah
but they made a smarter choice they
still my point is like they still gave
us that fan
service
but it didn't feel like fan service
it was rooted in its rich complex
larger-than-life
fantasy storytelling there like the
split choice
because it answers what happened with
the ancient one in that moment it
answers what exactly specific maneuver
she was doing and then on on top of that
they give us this cool battle between
them
but it's it and it's so interesting
because
it's it's so conflicting that's what i
loved about this it was so personal like
how can you not get where dark doctor
strange is coming from of course he's
gonna be this way you know and if you
are if you are someone with all that
power but but you don't know how to move
past it all and it also even raises that
question up of
damn you know he does that he just did
have that tom stone
he could he just done that whatever he
did yeah our doctor's range you know
and it's a good thing he didn't and it's
interesting to see uh like what happens
here when you mess with the with time
and then we're gonna get doctor strange
and spider-man
where he messes with time and then
something terrible goes wrong so it's
like a lot of the learning lessons and
marvel or don't mess with time you know
that was yeah that was one reason where
i'm like it can't be our universe is
doctor strange because otherwise the
spider-man's not going to happen yeah
yeah but yeah and i mean it had so many
great uh visual like i thought i felt
like i was getting swept up in a brad
bird movie while i was watching this in
the best way of like in the action and
the like the how bright and imaginative
a lot of the camera work and just a lot
of the capturing of the elements even
like the way they portrayed the magic
and the creatures and the absorption
it's like you know you know you know
it's the wrong anytime someone's
absorbing other creatures it's bad but
like even here they start you out with
him doing that in a way where it's like
kind of fun and then you know slowly it
just gets more and more monstrous and
even that has a natural build
i cared about him till the very end i
just felt sorry for the guy just felt
sorry and it was cool getting the other
version of him too
of the guy who just made the right
choice but he's still like that he does
have that struggle within himself he
gets where that that dark version of him
exists within him too oh yeah when when
when they have the whole confrontation
at the end and he's like i can't i want
to yes yeah live in this memory of love
with you but i can't you like i have to
let you go i just thought the rules of
this were so well flushed out like the
fabric of realities breaking and they
got that like oily melting effect
happening with them it's not another
dusting it's it's something else it
really feels like fabric is melting yeah
universes together and
and melting and rotting at the same time
what i loved about it is that while
that's happening we know it's happening
and then when he does ultimately you
know essentially save christine
immediately she starts to die again from
this
effect and i'm like you built i'm so
when i'm watching it the first time i'm
just like man this is heartbreaking this
is this is heart-wrenching yeah and also
just
such smart storytelling such
collaboration like oh damn
it's such a good tragedy like what a way
to justify it again yeah she's just
destined for this
centuries this guy's been pounding at
the magic
that's the like the most painful part is
you did it you succeeded but she's still
gonna die she's still destined to die
because the only way to do it was to
create a world so putrid she couldn't
live in it it's like i'm sure there's
some like cool easter eggs here and
there that flew over our heads and we'll
watch new rock stars videos yeah
that's their job yeah you know exactly
but what i loved is i felt like there
was so much
you know some religious imagery but it
also felt just like there was a lot of
symbolic ways of of composing this
particular episode right from the very
beginning with the glass shattering and
the looking like a heart shape you know
like your heart's been shattered um
but just like all like what you were
bringing up with the crystal at the end
encased in this forever piece of gre and
man
yeah like i used to really like talking
to the what if character um like whoa
that just
just
blew my mind i am not i know i'm not
articulate here right now
it's just when it happened i was just so
dazzled by it i was this brought me so
much wonder and i i feel like that's
usually the best kind of story telling
when they actually made the what if guy
a character you know he says i'm
watching or whatever but to have an
actual debate i thought that's what this
episode brought to life so well was that
it didn't just turn into action scene
action scene visual there was a constant
debate of the characters we're having
right down to when you get these two
versions of doctor strange they're in a
debate situation then he debates with
the watcher you know
like damn
what the hell just happened
it's your phone once i'm talking about
it comics explained just started playing
he wants it
he wants to point out the easter eggs
oh
yeah i know i i can't really find enough
things to say about this episode really
yeah it's like because you have doctor
strange and the ancient one and their
ability like
going back to the very beginning of what
we were talking about is like i think
that
adds to why this feels of greater
consequence and more connected is
because they are the beings in this
universe who can at least
sense the people watching over us and
sense you know the boundaries between
one reality and the next well it's like
he actually the thing that they did with
the watcher was that
he's always just felt like a narrator of
of these stories and then here he
becomes a character yeah yeah and it and
it retroactively makes that you know
appear you know i love it man that was
that was amazing this was it's like that
same kind of dazzle when you watch like
spider-man into the spider-verse yeah
and you're watching this and you're like
whoa this is the same show we've been
watching this is so this is so mature
and it's dealing with such adult themes
throughout yeah it's like when it
unlocks yeah it's like when it unlocks
that full potential of like just how
much imagination that pitch gives you of
like we're just gonna take all our
favorite characters and do any scenario
with them and then you like the last
three again like we've all had
fun yeah they've been fun and they've
been you know creative but this was like
nailing it yeah it's like yeah this is
really affecting it's really well put
together it's really well visualized and
conceived the voice performances are
really good oh my god yeah freaking
benedict cumberbatch coming off that you
know grinch movie yeah
who knows how to be warmed up on the
grinch rachel mcadams is great
i love the toying with the psychology of
the mind here there's those vision
sequences nightmarish sequences
nightmare hey and uh wong you even cared
about like i love that that that moment
between him and strange when he's like
at least gotta save you you know like
like i care about you you know i gotta
keep you alive like when he's when he's
in conflict
using conflict of like presented with
the choice to just give in and save
christine is the first flash he gets is
of wonky yeah yeah you know i'm like oh
damn he really cares about that guy
he's gonna be pissed if i don't come
love it it's amazing man and uh yeah
getting more ancient one in here this
was uh i i really uh i was really
impressed with this one and it was quite
dazzled whoa
um well i want to watch it again i
already want to watch it again i gotta
watch it on on a big tv now that was
amazing it's like and the great part is
is like you know even if you want to
show someone what if but they're like
you can just watch this one yeah you
can't you can't be like you can just
watch this one you
all right guys so what did you think
about this episode uh keep a lookout for
when we cover that new rockstars easter
egg breakdown video because you we're
gonna be on the lookout for that one
subscribe click that bell hit that like
button hey we'll catch you guys soon
wait wait sorry sorry i can't end this
without uh also mentioning that the
music was phenomenal in this episode
i'll just keep it at that
keep it at that man really near to
capture this wow just really
mystical and adventurous
who did the music
if only we had credits to find out rob
zombie
zombie really branching out boy
[Music]
you